thomas est né en 73
nous nous sommes mariés en 81 la veille
d'un 1er avril
question toute bête et c'était pour
régulariser c'était écoutez je ne sais
pas si je devrais parler de ces choses
là mais à l'époque j'avais un petit
problème de santé
et comme je suis d'un tempérament hyper
anxieux hypocondriaque etc
je me voyais déjà au paradis car l'enfer
est donc j'avais été j'avais été
consulté un avocat pour savoir ce qui se
passerait s'il m'arrivait quelque chose
il en est résulté que j'avais intérêt si
jamais il m'arriver quelque h au samedi
donc disons que tout le monde avait
intérêt à ce que jacques et moi soyons
marié c'est pour ça qu'on s'est mariée
tout bêtement je trouve ça très
intéressant voyez comme quoi on passe
devant monsieur le maire pour des
raisons en fait à faire mais parce que
je trouve que c'est enfin moi j'ai
toujours considéré le mariage comme une
formalité sans intérêt quoi uniquement
donc peut-être du point de vue social
mais pour soi c'est être ça n'a aucun
intérêt
ça ne change rien ça ne change rien
c'est pas ça qui va vous obliger qui va
faire que vous allez aimer rester avec
quelqu'un plus ou moins pour sa part dit
on a parlé de l'année 66 on vous a vu
avec michel polnareff et on a coutume de
réunir fait sur le temps certains
journaux les anciens de cette époque
vieillit quel regard vous portez
aujourd'hui sur 7 sur cette période
sur tous ces jeunes qu'on a découvert
comme ça avec salut les copains et ou
dont vous faisiez partie
est-ce que c'est du passé ou est-ce que
je vais revenir à cette question vous
avez l'impression d'avoir plusieurs vies
voilà c'est dit c'est dit s'ils doivent
en assam ça me paraît très très loin je
sais pas je ne peux pas vous répondre
précisément la seule chose que je puisse
vous dire c'est que le fait d'avoir
débuté d'avoir été comme ça plusieurs a
rencontré connaître un petit peu la même
aventure en même temps ça crée un petit
peu comme comme des liens comme un
esprit de solidarité de famille même si
je n'ai pas des liens extrêmement
étroits avec certains des artistes qui
ont débuté dans les années 60 comme moi
même j'ai débuté je me sens assez
solidaires d'eux je me sens assez
solidaire d'une fille comme sheila par
exemple comme sylvie m'enfin il ya
quelque chose qui ce qui ce qui se crée
à notre insu c'est pas mal quand j'ai
parce que j'ai l'impression que votre
carrière vous l'avez a bien mené alors
non ça je vous arrête tout de suite moi
je n'ai rien prémédité sur le plan de ma
carrière j'essaie comme j'ai pu et ni
plus ni moins c'est à dire les choses
que je pouvais pas faire je les ai
arrêté au bout d'un moment la scène donc
je me suis aperçu que je n'étais pas
fait pour ça ça me posait trop de
problèmes à tous les niveaux non d'abord
avec sur scène c'est pas vraiment mon
truc
ensuite voyager sans arrêt ça l'est
encore ça l'est encore moins
et donc donc j'ai fait ce pour quoi
j'avais l'impression que justement c'est
cette lucidité quand même assez
étonnante est ce que d'autres ont ont eu
des chemins beaucoup plus difficile
c'est parfois c'est la lucidité
d'autrefois cessé de l'instinct et puis
il ya aussi les conjonctures ya des
conjonctures qui sont porteuses et puis
d'autres qu'ils ne sont pas moins puis
je crois que ça ça change c'est pas
comme ça tout le temps je veux dire les
conjoncture porteuse peuvent devenir
négative du jour au lendemain et je
crois pas que ce soit tellement une
question de se tromper ou de ne pas se
tromper
[Musique]